- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Bonjour.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par Paul Molac.
- Paul Molac: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Au nom de mon groupe, je souhaite
avoir une pensée émue et exprimer
un soutien que je souhaite unanime
pour Yannick Morez, maire de
Saint-Brevin, en Loire-Atlantique.
Applaudissements nourris
- Debout!
Debout!
- Paul Molac: Il a été contraint à
la démission à la suite de
l'attaque de son domicile de la
part de l'extrême droite.
Nous devons condamner toutes les
violences, en particulier celles
contre les maires et élus locaux.
S'attaquer aux élus, c'est
s'attaquer aux fondements de notre
contrat social et à la République.
Nous avons découvert, il y a
plusieurs semaines, avec un
certain effroi le témoignage du
maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins,
faisant état de nombreuses
intimidations violentes qu'il a
subies.
Il a expliqué avoir reçu comme
seul soutien de l'Etat un coup de
téléphone de la part du
porte-parole du gouvernement quand
sa maison a été incendiée.
Il affirme ne pas avoir reçu de
protection policière.
La réponse de l'Etat n'a pas été à
la hauteur du danger.
C'est pourtant à l'Etat de le
protéger.
Les prises de position
gouvernementales en soutien aux
élus victimes de violences ne sont
pas suffisantes.
Ces violences se multiplient un
peu partout en France.
On vient de tout mettre en oeuvre
pour avoir des relations
respectueuses.
Madame la Première ministre,
qu'envisagez-vous pour faire
cesser ces violences et assurer la
sécurité des élus locaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin, ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, au nom du gouvernement, au
nom de la Première ministre, qui
s'est exprimée, nous voulons nous
associer aux propos de soutien que
vous avez tenus envers monsieur le
maire de Saint-Brevin et de tous
les élus de la République, quelles
que soient leurs convictions, qui
sont menacés dans leurs fonctions,
dans leur intimité, et,
évidemment, aucune cause ne mérite
la violence contre les élus, quels
qu'ils soient.
Je veux vous dire que nous avons
tous été très choqués, non
seulement des attaques que le
maire a connues, mais aussi des
attaques que de nombreux maires
reçoivent en France, ainsi que des
menaces, alors qu'ils essayent de
faire respecter l'environnement ou
la vie économique, ou encore quand
ils luttent contre les trafics en
tout genre.
Monsieur le député, lorsqu'un
maire est menacé, quand sa famille
est menacée, lorsqu'on porte
gravement atteinte à sa vie
personnelle en mettant des photos
sur les réseaux sociaux, en le
menaçant physiquement ou en
brûlant ses véhicules et ses
biens, c'est un échec pour la
République.
Nous pouvons toujours faire mieux.
Mieux dans la prévention.
Et avec Christophe Béchu, en
charge des collectivités locales,
je sais que tous les jours, nous
sommes aux côtés des élus locaux,
très courageux.
Mieux dans la protection.
C'est le cas du ministère de
l'Intérieur, des policiers et des
gendarmes.
Et mieux dans la condamnation.
Des enquêtes judiciaires ont été
ouvertes immédiatement par le
procureur de la République.
Il ne m'appartient pas de les
commenter.
Olivier Véran a appelé le maire de
Saint-Brevin.
La gendarmerie a pris trois fois
contact avec lui.
Sans doute que la protection
n'était pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'il attendait.
Nous pouvons nous améliorer, mais
il n'y a pas la main qui tremble
contre ceux qui menacent les élus
de la République.
- Paul Molac: Monsieur le
ministre, je crois qu'il faudrait
peut-être avoir des procédures
spéciales pour pouvoir protéger
véritablement les élus.
Lui n'a pas été protégé.
C'est le sentiment qu'il a donné
dans ce qu'il a pu dire à la télé.
Je souhaite évidemment que
l'apaisement revienne dans ce
pays, dans cet hémicycle, et je
pense que le gouvernement a une
grande importance...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur André
Chassaigne.
- André Chassaigne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, le
président de la République s'était
donné 100 jours pour apaiser la
colère des Français.
Une colère immense!
Sa réforme des retraites a été
élaborée sans négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux, sans dialogue
avec les forces politiques,
promulguée sans le vote des
représentants du peuple, malgré
une mobilisation massive des
salariés du privé et du public,
des jeunes comme des retraités, de
la France dans sa diversité.
Depuis le premier jour de la
mobilisation contre cette réforme,
cette France s'est levée contre le
recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite.
Elle s'est mobilisée pour
revendiquer le droit de vivre
dignement à tout âge.
Elle s'est insurgée contre le
47.1, contre le 49.3, contre
toutes vos manoeuvres pour imposer
votre réforme.
Elle a aussi espéré un référendum.
Quatre mois de mobilisation pour
exprimer une soif de justice
sociale et de respect.
Hier, le président a, une fois de
plus, été dans le déni de cette
réalité, dans la droite ligne des
propos tenus par différents
membres du gouvernement.
Il a osé prétendre que cette
France mobilisée n'était pas la
France, que votre gouvernement
serait trop intelligent pour être
compris de cette France-là.
Les 100 jours ne sont que
provocation.
De grâce, arrêtez-vous!
Cessez de piétiner le peuple et
ses représentants!
Cessez de faire croire que
l'extrême droite serait la seule
opposition respectable!
Cessez de diaboliser vos
opposants!
Le 6 juin sera le grand
rendez-vous de cette France qui
vous encombre.
Le 8 juin, nous porterons ici la
voix de cette France, en votant
l'abrogation de la réforme des
retraites.
Ce vote, vous ne pourrez
l'empêcher!
Vous ne pourrez l'empêcher...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le président.
Un peu de silence, s'il vous
plaît.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le président Chassaigne,
il y a un an, le président de la
République m'a fait l'honneur de
me nommer Première ministre.
Et depuis, nous avons continué à
mener les réformes nécessaires et
à répondre aux préoccupations des
Français.
Pouvoir d'achat, déconjugalisation
de l'AAH, énergie, sécurité,
réforme de l'assurance-chômage,
réforme des retraites...
27 textes ont été adoptés.
Quand certains misaient sur les
blocages, nous avons agi, nous
avons avancé.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
l'objectif du gouvernement, c'est
d'apporter des réponses concrètes
à nos concitoyens avec des
résultats rapides.
C'est la feuille de route que j'ai
présentée le 26 avril dernier.
Nous voulons gagner la bataille du
plein emploi.
Nous avons créé 1,7 million
d'emplois depuis six ans.
Le chômage est au plus bas depuis
15 ans.
Nous voulons poursuivre notre
réindustrialisation.
C'est le sens du projet de loi
présenté ce matin en Conseil des
ministres.
Nous voulons continuer à lever les
freins à l'emploi et permettre aux
acteurs de travailler davantage
ensemble.
C'est le projet de loi sur le
plein emploi qui sera présenté
prochainement.
Nous voulons que la richesse créée
bénéficie à tous.
Nous allons transcrire l''accord
sur le partage de la valeur
fidèlement.
Nous devons améliorer les
conditions de travail et de
rémunération, et je commencerai
tout à l'heure une série de
concertations avec les
organisations syndicales et
patronales.
Monsieur le président, j'en suis
convaincue, le dialogue social,
c'est la meilleure façon de
répondre aux attentes des
salariés.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
agir pour les Français, c'est
continuer à prendre à
bras-le-corps l'enjeu de la
transition écologique et mener une
planification écologique
ambitieuse.
Là encore, beaucoup de chantiers
ont été lancés.
Avec votre groupe, nous avons voté
la loi sur le nucléaire.
Les Français nous demandent plus
de services publics.
Ils demandent des solutions en
matière de santé et d'éducation.
Assurer les remplacements de
courte durée des professeurs,
permettre aux malades atteints de
maladies de longue durée d'avoir
un médecin traitant, voilà des
progrès concrets attendus par les
Français, que nous réaliserons
d'ici la fin de l'année.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
nous devons garantir l'ordre
républicain, en déployant de
nouveaux effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie, en préparant dans la
concertation un texte sur
l'immigration, en assurant notre
souveraineté avec la loi de
programmation militaire dont vous
débattrez la semaine prochaine, en
renforçant l'efficacité de notre
justice, tout en veillant à la
maîtrise de nos finances
publiques.
Monsieur le président Chassaigne,
le cap est clair: l'action et les
solutions au service des Français.
Avec la majorité et tous les
parlementaires de bonne volonté,
nous allons continuer à agir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Elie
Califer.
- Elie Califer: Merci, madame la
présidente.
En préambule, j'aimerais, au nom
de mon groupe, adresser un message
fraternel à tous les élus de la
République victimes
d'intimidations et de violences.
Je pense ici, aussi, à certains
maires de Guadeloupe, dont un qui
a été injustement agressé.
Je pense au courageux maire
démissionnaire de Saint-Brevin.
Face aux agressions et aux
menaces, en particulier celles de
l'extrême droite, nous ferons
toujours front pour défendre nos
élus, pour défendre la République
et les valeurs d'égalité, de
solidarité et de fraternité.
J'en viens maintenant à ma
question qui s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre des Outre-mer.
Face à l'explosion des prix des
billets d'avion, tous les élus des
outre-mer tirent, depuis plusieurs
mois, la sonnette d'alarme.
Tous dénoncent à l'unisson le côté
artificiel de cette flambée des
prix.
Tous vous apportent des solutions
de bon sens.
Alors que l'été approche, que nos
étudiants cherchent à retrouver
leur famille désespérément, rien
ne bouge, si ce n'est que les prix
augmentent.
Pour contrer cette explosion
tarifaire, une idée soi-disant
lumineuse refait surface depuis
quelques jours: l'idée de la
création d'une compagnie Air
Outre-mer, une super-compagnie
fusionnant tous les acteurs du
secteur, un mastodonte aérien qui
se partagerait le ciel avec Air
France pour les vols à destination
de nos outre-mer.
Monsieur le ministre, une telle
vision a de quoi inquiéter.
Elle inquiète d'autant plus que ce
projet serait fait par un fonds
d'investissement qui va
privilégier l'intérêt des
compagnies au pouvoir d'achat des
familles.
Vous le savez, la concurrence n'a
jamais fait baisser les prix, bien
au contraire.
Le gouvernement est-il favorable à
ce projet?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Clément
Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, merci, au nom
du gouvernement, pour les mots que
vous avez eus contre toute forme
de violence.
Sur la question que vous soulevez,
que je suis de près, je vais être
très clair: vous avez soulevé la
question des prix des billets
d'avion.
Pour revenir sur ce point
important pour la vie quotidienne,
je voudrais d'abord vous dire que
ces prix augmentent en large
partie en raison de la hausse des
carburants.
La hausse que nous constatons sur
les prix depuis et à destination
des outre-mer est similaire ou
inférieure à la hausse que nous
voyons sur tout le trafic longue
distance en matière aérienne.
Ca ne veut pas dire que nous ne
pouvons pas agir.
L'Agence des outre-mer pour la
mobilité a soutenu, cette année,
l'achat de 60.000 billets d'avion.
Nous devons aller plus loin.
Avec plusieurs leviers, que vous
avez évoqués, nous devons, par
exemple, maintenir une concurrence
importante sur les liaisons
d'outre-mer.
Nous travaillons à sauver les
offres aériennes et les
compagnies, comme l'Etat l'a fait
depuis 2020 avec des
investissements importants.
Nous ne voulons certainement pas
réduire la concurrence ou à avoir
une forme de monopole sur les
outre-mer.
Nous recevrons tous les élus
d'outre-mer qui le souhaitent dans
les prochaines semaines pour faire
un point sur cette question
spécifique.
Je convoquerai également les
compagnies aériennes concernées
pour faire un point sur
l'encadrement des prix pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de hausses indues qui
seraient captées par les
compagnies aériennes.
Enfin, avec le ministre, nous
lançons une refonte des aides de
l'Agence des outre-mer.
Nous avons augmenté le soutien
cette année.
Cela a un effet important.
Nous travaillerons avec vous pour
aller au-delà, si vous êtes
d'accord.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Yannick
Haury.
- Yannick Haury: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
ancien maire de Saint-Brevin, je
veux redire ici notre émotion face
à la démission du maire actuel,
Yannick Morez, après une violente
agression.
Je lui redis toute notre
solidarité.
Applaudissements nourris
...
- C'est honteux!
- Yannick Haury: Cet événement est
révélateur de l'augmentation des
violences qui touchent les élus de
la République.
Je les condamne toutes, sans
aucune ambiguïté, et d'où qu'elles
viennent.
Il est inacceptable que, dans
notre République, les élus, et, en
première ligne, les maires,
subissent des insultes, des
menaces, des intimidations, du
harcèlement ou des agressions.
L'escalade, la surenchère ou la
banalisation des actes violents
auxquels nous assistons doivent
cesser.
Des voies de recours existent dans
notre Constitution pour s'opposer
à la violence, qu'elle soit
verbale, morale ou physique.
Elle n'a pas sa place et ne doit
jamais être une réponse.
Tout acte de violence doit être
dénoncé dès le premier fait.
A chaque fois, ce sont nos
institutions qui sont visées, qui
sont touchées, et la démocratie
qui recule.
Nous ne pouvons tolérer
l'instrumentalisation qui est
faite par des groupuscules
politiques extrémistes.
La République a besoin de ses
élus, car ce sont eux qui font
vivre au quotidien la démocratie
sur le terrain.
Ils doivent bénéficier d'une
protection à la hauteur de leur
engagement et de leurs
responsabilités.
Madame la Première ministre,
pouvez-vous nous dire comment le
gouvernement entend poursuivre son
action pour soutenir nos élus et
les protéger plus efficacement, en
intervenant le plus tôt possible
et le plus fermement possible?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Yannick Haury,
s'en prendre à un élu, quel que
soit son mandat, quelle que soit
son étiquette, c'est s'en prendre
à la République.
Ce qui est arrivé à Yannick Morez,
le maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins,
dans votre circonscription, est
inacceptable, inqualifiable.
Monsieur Morez a été victime de la
vindicte, du harcèlement, des
intimidations de groupuscules
d'extrême droite.
La semaine dernière, son domicile
a été incendié.
Le gouvernement est à ses côtés.
Je sais que la très grande
majorité d'entre vous le soutient.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
les maires sont les visages de la
République dans chacun de nos
territoires.
Leur mission est essentielle.
Elle demande des sacrifices, et
ils le savent, mais les menaces et
les violences n'en font pas
partie.
Je suis consciente que condamner
ne suffit pas.
Mon gouvernement prend à
bras-le-corps la question des
violences envers les élus.
Chaque jour, avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur, nous protégeons les
maires, les parlementaires et tous
les élus menacés.
Les préfets, les policiers, les
gendarmes...
Tous sont aux côtés des élus pour
les protéger quand ils sont pris
pour cible.
Cette action au plus près du
terrain est indispensable, mais
elle doit s'accompagner de mesures
plus structurelles.
C'est pour cela que la ministre
chargée des Collectivités
territoriales, Dominique Faure,
présentera demain un dispositif
pour mieux prévenir les violences
et accompagner les élus.
Il a été préparée depuis plusieurs
mois.
J'avais eu l'occasion d'échanger
avec l'ensemble des associations
d'élus sur cette démarche, dès le
12 avril dernier.
Cela nous permettra de mieux
intervenir en amont, en repérant
les menaces, et de sanctionner
plus fermement les auteurs.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
demain, je recevrai le maire
démissionnaire de Saint-Brevin,
ainsi que l'association des maires
de Loire-Atlantique et
l'association des maires de France
pour leur dire notre soutien et
évoquer les solutions que nous
mettons en place.
Le civisme, le respect des élus,
c'est le fondement du pacte
démocratique et républicain.
Nous continuerons à nous battre
pour les défendre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Matthias
Tavel.
- Matthias Tavel: Madame la
présidente, madame la Première
ministre, mercredi dernier, le
maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
démissionnait.
Quelques semaines plus tôt, le 22
mars, un incendie criminel à son
domicile menaçait de le tuer,
ainsi que sa famille.
Nous voulons saluer cet homme, cet
élu local, son engagement pour ses
concitoyens.
Nous comprenons...
Applaudissements nourris
Nous comprenons sa décision, car
elle est profondément humaine.
Elle est une meurtrissure pour la
République.
Ce maire a démissionné, car il a
été agressé par l'extrême droite
et abandonné par l'Etat face à
elle, c'est-à-dire par vous.
Pourquoi a-t-il fallu plus de 10
jours pour que le président de la
République exprime sa solidarité
après l'incendie?
Pourquoi le ministre de
l'Intérieur ne s'est-il jamais
rendu à Saint-Brevin pour soutenir
ce maire et le projet de Cada,
pourtant porté par son propre
ministère?
Le sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire
a-t-il vraiment refusé une
proposition de protection
rapprochée à ce maire?
Pourquoi le préfet de
Loire-Atlantique n'a-t-il pas
interdit la manifestation du 29
avril, laissant l'extrême droite
parader jusqu'à Saint-Brevin?
Est-ce monsieur Gérald Darmanin
qui a donné des instructions
complaisantes envers l'extrême
droite, lui qui trouve madame Le
Pen trop molle?
Face à l'extrême droite, à son
racisme, nous appelons tous nos
concitoyens à se rassembler le 24
mai prochain à Saint-Brevin.
Madame la Première ministre, nous
apprenons par la presse des
projets d'attentats portés par
l'extrême droite, visant le CRIF,
des mosquées, Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
sans que les personnes ciblées
n'aient été prévenues par les
autorités.
Existe-t-il d'autres menaces de
cet ordre?
Quand allez-vous enfin affronter
l'extrême droite au lieu de
l'alimenter par votre politique
injuste et de la protéger par
votre inaction contre ces
violences?
Allez-vous renvoyer le ministre de
l'Intérieur?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, que l'émotion
soit partagée, c'est une chose.
Que l'on évite la récupération,
c'en est une autre.
J'ai été maire, comme Gérald
Darmanin, comme d'autres ici.
Les menaces, les insultes, les
outrages, les fake news sur les
réseaux sociaux, les mises en
cause, les invectives, elles
viennent de partout, quand vous
êtes maire, de l'extrême droite et
de l'extrême gauche.
La violence...
La violence, c'est trop facile!
La violence, c'est trop facile de
la condamner après!
Quand condamnez-vous les
conseillers régionaux LFI qui
manifestent en disant qu'ils
peuvent décapiter Macron, comme
Louis XVI?
Votre indignation est sélective!
A quel moment vous n'encouragez
pas cette violence dans la façon
dont vous vous exprimez ici?
Les maires de France méritent
mieux que de servir de
punching-ball
entre l'opposition!
La vérité, c'est que défendre les
maires, c'est protéger la
démocratie, c'est faire attention
à la manière dont on s'exprime
ici, c'est témoigner du respect
quand un membre du gouvernement ou
quand un autre député prend la
parole!
Ce n'est pas seulement monter en
épingle un fait divers tragique,
scandaleux, où l'extrême droite
est en cause en l'espèce!
C'est assumer dans tous les cas de
dénoncer les scandales et c'est
éviter d'appeler à la protection
policière quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon
explique que la police ne protège
pas, mais qu'elle tue.
C'est ça aussi, la continuité!
Au milieu de tout ça, soyez
cohérents!
Combattons toutes les violences,
d'où qu'elles viennent, avec la
même force!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
Merci beaucoup.
La parole...
La parole est à monsieur Erwan
Balanant.
- Erwan Balanant: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Le groupe démocrate s'associe au
soutien au maire de Saint-Brevin
et à tous les élus de la
République.
Mais le groupe démocrate est
choqué que certains soient restés
assis.
Nous sommes scandalisés!
Levons-nous!
Aujourd'hui, les extrêmes sortent
de l'ombre, décomplexés, espérant
que la République se meurt et que
leur violence soit une solution.
Le fleuve de notre détermination
républicaine démocratique ne peut
se tarir face à des minorités qui
n'ont que les armes de la peur et
du mensonge pour exister.
N'oublions pas notre histoire.
La République est un combat.
Cette violence assumée, débridée,
qui menace les élus, nos
institutions, et qui tabasse un
simple citoyen ne doit pas devenir
la norme et supplanter les
véritables actions citoyennes.
Notre jeunesse s'engage.
Elle fait de son quotidien les
combats pour l'écologie, la
liberté, l'égalité.
Je voudrais les remercier pour
leur résilience et leur
abnégation.
C'est à nous de porter ce sursaut
civique.
Dans cet hémicycle, nous portons
tous une part de responsabilité
dans ce furieux engrenage.
Certains ont oublié que le débat
et le combat politique ne sont pas
synonyme de violence.
L'attitude policée de nos
collègues du Rassemblement
National, qui restent assis, ne
doit pas nous faire perdre de vue
que l'extrême droite est un danger
pour notre République.
Je vous rappellerai les mots de
Baudelaire: "La plus belle des
ruses du diable est de nous
persuader qu'il n'existe pas."
Comment pouvons-nous améliorer
notre société...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Balanant,
d'abord, depuis quelques années,
il y a eu deux oeuvres utiles pour
renforcer de manière concrète la
protection des élus.
Je veux saluer la loi Lecornu, qui
a été à l'initiative de cette
majorité et qui a rendu possible
le fait qu'il puisse y avoir une
protection renforcée pour
l'ensemble des élus, et, plus
récemment, à la demande de
l'association des maires de
France, une loi a rendu possible à
la fois pour les deux chambres du
Parlement, mais également pour
l'ensemble des associations d'élus
de pouvoir se porter partie civile
aux côtés de ceux qui sont
directement menacés.
La suite, c'est la réponse pénale,
et c'est l'accompagnement.
Quelques chiffres.
2256: c'est le nombre d'atteintes,
en 2022, à des élus.
C'est un chiffre en forte
augmentation.
+30% par rapport à l'année qui
précède.
Dans 70% des cas, il s'agit
d'insultes, de menaces,
d'invectives, mais dans 30%,
d'actes dans lesquels l'intégrité
physique des élus peut être mise
en cause.
L'année dernière, 650 réponses
pénales ont été apportées.
Depuis le début de cette année,
des centaines de procédures ont
été lancées et, déjà, 171
sanctions pénales ont été
prononcées.
Protéger nos élus, ce n'est pas
seulement s'émouvoir, c'est bien
sûr être capable de condamner avec
la plus grande force les attaques,
en ne faisant pas d'indignation
sélective.
C'est renforcer les mesures.
Les symboles ont un sens.
Ce n'est pas anodin, de rester
assis, quand on met en cause
l'honneur d'un élu.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Kévin
Mauvieux.
- Kévin Mauvieux: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mes chers collègues, cette
question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
"Mensonge": voilà un mot qui
résume la macronie.
Depuis des mois, vous nous répétez
que l'inflation va ralentir, que
le pouvoir d'achat va augmenter.
Vous nous annoncez une baisse des
prix de l'alimentaire de 5%.
Quelle honte, de mentir aussi
effrontément aux Français.
Mensonge, encore, quand Olivia
Grégoire nous annonce une baisse
de 13% des prix dans le panier
anti-inflation, annonce aussitôt
ridiculisée par les associations
de consommateurs compétentes que
vous insultez désormais.
L'INSEE lui-même indique que les
prix de l'alimentaire explosent,
avec, en moyenne, près de 15%
d'inflation sur ces produits, et
jusqu'à 30% sur la viande.
Je vous invite à aller dans un
supermarché pour faire des
courses, et non des photos, pour
faire votre plein de courses et
non pour boire les paroles d'un
géant de la distribution.
Trop de mensonges entraînent la
contradiction.
Pourquoi Bruno Le Maire se sent
obligée d'intimer l'ordre aux
distributeurs de baisser leurs
prix d'ici juin, si les prix ont
déjà baissé?
La baisse des prix alimentaires ne
se décrète pas par 49.3.
Monsieur le ministre, les prix de
l'alimentaire ne se décident pas
dans un roman, dont vous écrivez
l'histoire.
"Incapable": ce sont les mots qui
reviennent dans la bouche des
Français quand ils vous entendent.
Quand allez-vous arrêter de mentir
aux Français?
Quand allez-vous reconnaître
l'échec de votre politique sur le
pouvoir d'achat et l'inflation?
Quand allez-vous penser aux
Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Si tant est que la réponse à la
question posée intéresse ceux qui
m'accusent de mentir, je suggère
de répondre que le mensonge, il
est là.
Le mensonge, c'est faire croire
que supprimer la TVA sur 100
produits de première nécessité
ferait baisser l'inflation.
Le mensonge, il est de faire
croire qu'en baissant cette TVA,
regardez nos amis espagnols,
l'inflation alimentaire
disparaîtrait.
Le mensonge, ça fait 18 mois que
vous l'entretenez.
Entre mensonge et fainéantise, mon
coeur balance.
L'inflation galope, mais le
Rassemblement National n'a qu'une
seule proposition depuis deux ans
pour accompagner les Français...
Les courses, nous les faisons, et
probablement bien plus que
beaucoup d'entre vous.
On va être très précis.
Les Français méritent des
explications, à la suite de vos
accusations.
La Direction générale de la
concurrence et de la répression
des fraudes a analysé 1700
produits.
La précision ne vous intéresse
pas, mais elle intéressera
peut-être ceux qui nous écoutent.
Ces 1700 produits ont été
décortiqués.
On voit une baisse de 13% en
moyenne chez les distributeurs
Auchan, Carrefour, Casino,
Franprix et Système U.
Je précise, parce qu'on parle
d'études, que cette étude a été
faite par la Direction de la
répression des fraudes avant le
trimestre anti-inflation, et après
sa mise en application.
Si ça vous intéresse, avec une
calculette, vous ferez l'exercice
vous-même.
Le prix du panier est passé de
3439 euros à 3003 euros.
Ca vous évitera de raconter
n'importe quoi et de m'accuser de
mensonges.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Alexandre
Portier.
- Alexandre Portier: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Pap Ndiaye, ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
Monsieur le ministre, l'Education
nationale va enfin être première
quelque part.
L'Education nationale va décrocher
la palme du plus mauvais employeur
de France.
Votre réforme du lycée
professionnel en est la cause.
En Je suis très choqué de la
méthode et des propos employés.
Vous prévoyez des fermetures de
filières.
Vous dites aux enseignants qu'ils
peuvent "se diriger vers le
professorat des écoles ou des
collèges".
J'ai cru que c'était un canular.
La blague était bien sérieuse.
Les enseignants en vente ou en
gestion vont dorénavant enseigner
la lecture en CP ou l'Europe
médiévale en cinquième?
Dans quel monde vivez-vous?
C'est comme si on vous débarquait
pour vous mettre à l'industrie ou
aux finances.
C'est inconcevable.
Allez une semaine dans une classe
et vous comprendrez que ce ne sont
pas les mêmes métiers, pas les
mêmes choix de vie.
Pour beaucoup, vos propos sont la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le
vase.
Jeudi dernier, nous étions à
Montrouge dans un lycée
professionnel.
Un enseignant a parlé de
"dépotoir" pour dire sa colère
face à l'Etat et à la gestion des
lycées professionnels en France.
C'était un cri du coeur.
Il n'en pouvait plus du mépris de
l'institution pour cette filière
qui devrait être la voie royale et
non pas la voie de garage.
Pourquoi un tel mépris pour les
enseignants des lycées
professionnels?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Carole Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Portier.
Nous partageons largement ici le
constat de cette transformation du
lycée professionnel, qui doit
accompagner une meilleure réussite
des élèves et accompagner le lycée
professionnel pour qu'il devienne
une voie de choix, reconnue par
l'ensemble de la société.
Nous travaillons sur les
fragilités des élèves pour mieux
les accompagner dans ce parcours.
Nous allons rapprocher le lycée de
l'environnement économique qui est
le sien et mieux préparer les
élèves à leur avenir.
Cela passera par un bureau
école-entreprise, par des stages
dont la durée sera augmentée en
terminale, et cela passera aussi
par une meilleure préparation des
jeunes.
Nous allons accompagner
l'engagement des équipes
professorales, l'ensemble des
équipes éducatives, par des moyens
inédits.
C'est plus de 1 milliard d'euros
engagés.
Au-delà de ça, ce sont des
effectifs de professeurs que nous
maintenons à la rentrée prochaine,
et 400 effectifs que nous mettons
sur les lycées professionnels avec
des infirmiers, des CPE
et des assistants sociaux pour
renforcer les équipes
pédagogiques.
C'est un investissement majeur que
nous allons faire, avec 2,5
milliards d'euros pour accompagner
les nouveaux plateaux techniques
ainsi que la formation des
enseignants, et des proviseurs.
Nous avons besoin des enseignants.
Ce sont des experts de la
pédagogie, notamment en lycée
professionnel.
C'est avec eux que nous devons
travailler.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Alexandre Portier: Tout ça,
c'est de la langue de bois.
Les enseignants ne sont pas des
pions, ce sont des personnes avec
un choix de vie, un projet.
Ils méritent le respect et la
dignité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Charles Rodwell
pour Renaissance.
- Charles Rodwell: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Economie et des Finances.
13 milliards d'euros
d'investissement, 8000 emplois
créés, c'est le bilan de l'édition
2023 de Choose France, qui s'est
tenue hier sur ma circonscription.
Depuis quatre ans, la France est
le pays le plus attractif pour les
investissements étrangers.
Depuis quatre ans, les entreprises
françaises et étrangères nous
réaffirment le même message: elles
ont confiance en la France, en
notre économie, en notre réponse
aux crises successives.
Enfin, depuis six ans, nous avons
bâti une vraie politique
industrielle.
Nous avons baissé massivement les
impôts pour les ménages et pour
les entreprises.
Nous allons continuer.
Nous avons réformé notre marché du
travail pour créer 1,7 million
d'emplois depuis 2017.
Nous avons soutenu notre appareil
productif à travers les plans
France 2030 et France Relance.
La France rouvre des nouvelles
usines pour la première fois
depuis 30 ans.
Le président s'est rendu vendredi
à Dunkerque.
Cela en est le symbole.
6000 emplois industriels détruits
sur les dernières années, 16.000
emplois créés dans les 10 années
qui viennent.
Notre politique industrielle donne
des résultats.
Nous allons l'accélérer.
C'est l'objet du projet de loi
Industrie verte.
Vous voulez accélérer les délais
d'importation en préservant notre
environnement?
Quelles sont les mesures pour
atteindre cet objectif?
Aussi, vous avez toujours veillé à
ce que la relance industrielle
soit juste pour bénéficier à
toutes nos régions.
Quelles mesures proposées vont en
ce sens?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Depuis le début des années 1980,
la France a détruit 2,6 millions
d'emplois industriels, fermé 600
usines.
C'est la pire catastrophe
économique que notre pays ait
connue depuis 40 ans.
Depuis 2017, nous avons enfin une
vraie politique industrielle
nationale.
Avec la baisse des impôts, une
meilleure formation, la
suppression des impôts de
production, le résultat est
incontestable.
300 usines ouvertes au lieu des
600 qui ont été détruites, 90.000
emplois industriels créés par la
politique de cette majorité, par
vos décisions, mesdames et
messieurs les députés de la
majorité.
Nous voulons maintenant accélérer
ce projet de loi sur l'Industrie
verte.
Nous voulons accélérer pour mettre
à disposition de tous les
industriels qui voudraient
investir sur notre territoire des
terrains, pour ouvrir des usines
ou agrandir les usines existantes,
accélérer les procédures
administratives avec des délais
divisés par 2.
Nous voulons qu'en France, on ne
mette plus 17 mois pour ouvrir une
usine, mais 9 mois pour ouvrir de
nouvelles installations
industrielles.
Nous voulons mettre à disposition
les financements nécessaires, des
subventions, des crédits d'impôts
comme autorisé par l'Union
Européenne, et un nouveau plan
d'épargne verte pour les jeunes
avec zéro impôts, zéro charges
pour que les jeunes investissent
dans l'industrie de demain et dans
la décarbonation de notre
industrie.
Nous voulons, naturellement,
favoriser et protéger notre
industrie.
Il n'est pas normal que le bonus
électrique aille à des véhicules
construits en dehors de l'Europe.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Yoann Gillet pour
le Rassemblement National.
- Yoann Gillet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur, un contexte de
violence amène des élus de tous
bords, abandonnés par l'Etat, à la
démission.
Au nom de mon groupe, j'adresse à
ces serviteurs de la République
tout mon soutien.
Dans ce contexte, j'ai été alerté
par un maire de ma circonscription
sur une occupation illégale du
domaine public par des forains,
qui ne sont pas représentatifs de
la profession.
Alors que cette commune en
accueille toute l'année avec
plaisir, ces forains-là se sont
accaparé le domaine public, ont
volé du courant et menacé un
employé municipal.
Ils voulaient donner des
représentations de sports
motorisés sans autorisation
préfectorale.
Le maire, qui voulait assurer
l'ordre public, a saisi la justice
en référé pour obtenir leur
expulsion.
L'audience a eu lieu aujourd'hui,
après la bataille.
Abandonné par l'Etat, ce maire,
qui avait en vain alerté le
préfet, a décidé d'aller lui-même
sur place pour alerter les
habitants.
J'ai été à ses côtés avec de
nombreux élus et agents de la
ville, notamment la police
municipale.
Face au rappel du droit, certains
de ces forains ont diffamé le
maire, l'ont violenté, et ont
tenté un homicide avec un camion à
l'encontre d'un autre élu.
L'indemnité mensuelle de ces élus
est de moins de 200 euros.
Quatre plaintes ont été déposées.
Grâce à la ténacité et au courage
Dans beaucoup d'autres villes, les
élus, seuls face aux menaces,
abandonnent.
Ces délinquants ont indiqué à
plusieurs reprises qu'ils allaient
revenir en représailles et bloquer
la ville pour la grande foire de
l'Ascension.
Trouvez-vous cela admissible que
les élus soient seuls face aux
menaces?
Comment comptez-vous gérer en
termes de sécurité la journée de
jeudi dans cette commune?
Pourquoi un homme accusé de
tentative d'homicide avec arme par
destination est-il toujours en
liberté, 72 heures après les
faits?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Gérald Darmanin, ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député.
S'il y a bien quelque chose qui
nous étonne et qui aurait pu vous
inspirer à la modestie, c'est de
vous excuser pour le climat dans
lequel vous mettez les élus qui
veulent accueillir des personnes
immigrées dans votre territoire.
Ca aurait été à la hauteur de
votre engagement.
Je pense qu'un peu de retenue,
quand on voit les résultats de vos
interventions médiatiques et
l'action de vos militants.
Je vous ai trouvé beaucoup moins
agressif quand nous avons échangé
ce week-end.
Vous n'avez pas eu un mot
pour la préfète et mon cabinet
qui ont répondu à vos appels.
Je tiens à disposition les
échanges épistolaires et textuels
que nous avons eus.
Si vous souhaitez que le ministre
de l'Intérieur gère le ministère
de la Justice, on n'a pas la même
conception de la République.
Il y a eu un recours, la décision
a été donnée et sera appliquée.
La différence entre vous et nous,
c'est qu'on applique le droit de
la République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Julien Bayou pour
le groupe Ecologiste.
- Julien Bayou: Madame la
présidente, ma question s'adresse
au ministère de l'Agriculture.
Il y a 60 ans, une écologiste a
été moquée pour son livre qui
prédisait la disparition
d'oiseaux.
Il est aujourd'hui attesté que 20
millions d'oiseaux disparaissent
chaque année.
Pour que tout le monde comprenne,
cette étude est qualifiée par le
CNRS de "la plus complète jamais
réalisée".
37 années de données, et une
conclusion scientifique:
l'agriculture intensive donne lieu
à l'effondrement de la
biodiversité.
Que faites-vous?
Une pause.
Vous tergiversez sur le glyphosate
et demandez aux agriculteurs de ne
pas utiliser les pesticides.
L'agriculture biologique peut nous
nourrir sans menacer la
biodiversité.
Je n'ai pas le temps de parler
longtemps des bienfaits de
l'agriculture biologique.
L'agriculture biologique, c'est
30% de consommation d'eau en
moins, plus d'emplois, une
meilleure rémunération des
agriculteurs.
Le bio n'est pas plus cher mais
est moins subventionné.
La filière est fragilisée par
votre choix de supprimer l'aide au
maintien et son prix est enchéri
par les marges de centrales
d'achat.
Les magasins bio ferment et les
agriculteurs bio ne s'en sortent
plus.
La filière se meurt.
Pourtant, il y a une solution
simple: appliquer la loi.
Il y a 20% de produits bio
proposés normalement dans les
cantines.
On en est loin.
Nous pourrions sauver la filière
avec ce débouché et offrir une
alimentation de qualité.
Nous vous demandons d'appliquer la
loi pour sauver la filière bio.
Il faut faire le choix de
l'agriculture bio.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires.
- Christophe Béchu: Monsieur
Julien Bayou.
D'abord, je présente les excuses
de Marc Fesneau, qui ne peut pas
être ici, mais qui aura l'occasion
demain de présenter des annonces
en faveur de la filière bio suite
à la réunion sur la planification
écologique et la transition
agricole qui a été présidée par la
Première ministre le 4 mai dernier
et qui s'inscrit dans le schéma de
planification écologique qui sera
présenté à la fin du mois de juin.
La réalité, c'est qu'on a eu une
année 2022 complexe après un
quinquennat où, en moyenne, nous
avons connu 15% de conversions au
bio par an en plus.
Avec les mesures prises par cette
majorité, comme le crédit d'impôt
en faveur du bio, qui représente
110 millions d'euros d'efforts en
2023, soit 53 millions de plus que
l'année dernière.
L'année 2022 a été marquée par le
tassement des conversions, 9%.
On a eu beaucoup de déconversions,
bien plus que de conversions.
Avec les études humaines sur
l'obésité, le diabète, sur la
biodiversité, les bienfaits du bio
sont avérés.
Tout l'enjeu, c'est de faire en
sorte de prolonger les aides déjà
annoncées.
C'est le deuxième pilier de la
PAC, dont les crédits ont été
augmentés.
Ce sont les annonces qui vont
arriver
demain.
Gardez-vous d'être trop manichéen.
Il y a des réalités sur les
territoires, des disparités.
Le sujet, ce n'est pas que le bio,
c'est aussi le local et de faire
en sorte qu'on soit capables de
joindre les deux bouts en termes
d'emplois et de biodiversité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Marie-Agnès
Poussier-Winsback pour le groupe
Horizon.
- Marie-Agnès Poussier-Winsback:
Merci.
Chers collègues, les agissements
contre le maire de Saint-Brevin,
les actes d'intimidation dont sont
victimes les élus locaux,
départementaux, européens,
nationaux, sont inacceptables.
Certains de nos collègues, nos
enfants, nos conjoints, ont
parfois peur d'être pris à partie
ou de rentrer chez eux, chez nous.
Je voudrais rappeler que dans
notre pays, il n'existe pas de
bons ou de mauvais élus selon nos
étiquettes, selon les décisions
que nous prenons.
Nous avons tous été élus au niveau
local, national, par le peuple, et
les élections sont là pour nous
sanctionner ou nous renouveler.
La violence ne saurait jamais être
justifiée.
Je suis consciente que des mesures
ont été prises récemment pour
mieux sanctionner de tels actes,
notamment grâce à la loi
Engagement et proximité, que les
associations nationales peuvent se
constituer partie civile, mais
nous devons montrer plus de
fermeté comme l'avait été
souhaité.
Nous devons permettre aux élus de
mieux se protéger et de mieux
protéger.
Qui osera demain se présenter aux
élections si nous devenons des
cibles?
Qui osera relever demain les défis
auxquels, nous le savons, nous
allons tous être confrontés,
qu'ils soient écologiques,
numériques, démographiques, si la
violence devient la réponse à
toutes nos volontés de changement?
L'annonce d'un centre d'analyse et
de lutte aux atteintes aux élus
est une bonne initiative, mais il
faut aller plus loin.
Quels moyens pourrions-nous mettre
en place pour que notre démocratie
continue à vivre dans nos villes,
villages et assemblées?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés.
Demain après-midi, Dominique Faure
va préciser ce que ce centre de
lutte contre les atteintes aux
élus aura vocation à faire.
Coordonner, recenser, faire en
sorte que nous puissions disposer
d'une analyse plus précise sur ce
qu'il se passe afin que nous
soyons plus réactifs.
Connaître, c'est bien.
Réagir, c'est mieux.
Il y a eu, je tiens à le dire, une
action de sensibilisation à tous
les élus.
25.000 élus ont bénéficié de temps
de formation avec la gendarmerie
pour savoir comment réagir à ces
atteintes.
Plus loin que ça, 3429, c'est le
nombre de gendarmes et de
policiers qui ont été formés à
l'intérieur du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour être les
référents des élus.
La suite, c'est la réflexion que
nous devons avoir sur ce que ces
violences à destination des élus
reflètent.
Nous avons, ici, de façon presque
unanime, considéré que le port de
l'uniforme, qui représente la
République, devenait une
circonstance aggravante contre
ceux qui s'en prenaient aux
pompiers, aux policiers, aux
gendarmes.
Le port de l'écharpe, même s'il
n'est pas permanent, reflète
exactement la même réalité.
Il représente les valeurs de la
République et ce indépendamment
des opinions de chacun.
La légitimité de la représentation
est une manière de faire vivre la
République.
Cela fait partie des sujets qui
sont sur la table.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Emmanuelle
Anthoine pour Les Républicains.
- Emmanuelle Anthoine: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, alors
que le président de la République
court dans toute la France après
sa popularité perdue sans annoncer
de véritables réformes pour le
pays, pendant qu'il évolue dans sa
bulle médiatique entre deux
cordons de sécurité, la violence
flambe dans nos territoires,
notamment dans les villes
moyennes.
La semaine dernière, en quatre
jours, trois meurtres se sont
succédés à Valence.
Le quotidien des habitants des
deux quartiers concernés, sur fond
de guerre de territoire, de trafic
de drogue, est intenable.
Nous retrouvons cette violence
partout dans le pays.
Sur l'année écoulée, les homicides
sont 30% plus nombreux qu'en 2017.
Nous assistons à la brutalisation
de notre société.
Cette brutalisation peut nous
mener à l'abîme.
La République doit faire peur de
fermeté.
Il vous appartient de garantir la
sécurité, première des libertés.
Force est de constater votre échec
en matière de lutte contre
l'insécurité.
C'est l'autorité de l'Etat.
Il faut la rétablir.
Pour cela, il faut des forces de
l'ordre plus nombreuses.
Elles font face à des moyens
insuffisants.
Il faut renforcer la sécurité en
améliorant le dialogue entre les
maires et l'Etat, et en renforçant
les pouvoirs des polices
municipales.
Il faut redonner à notre justice
les moyens d'accomplir sa mission,
alors que nos tribunaux, comme
celui de Valence, manquent de
moyens.
Quand allez-vous répondre aux
attentes légitimes de sécurité des
Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Il y a eu
effectivement à Villerupt et
Valence ces derniers jours des
règlements de compte, des
assassinats, sur fond de trafic de
drogue.
Il se trouve que dans ces deux
villes de la Drôme, les enquêtes
avancent et des personnes ont été
interpellées.
Cela va entraîner la sanction de
ces personnes.
Bien sûr, ce qui se passe à
Valence est inacceptable.
J'y ai dépêché une compagnie de
CRS.
L'augmentation des effectifs au
commissariat est sans précédent
depuis cinq ans, alors que les
effectifs avaient baissé depuis
une vingtaine d'années dans la
Drôme.
Ceci explique cela.
Il n'est pas tout à fait vrai,
cependant, malgré ces faits divers
inacceptables, de constater que la
délinquance augmente dans notre
pays.
J'aurai l'occasion cet après-midi
même de rendre publics les
chiffres de l'année.
Vous constaterez que le travail
collectif de la police et de la
justice ont augmenté, vous avez
d'ailleurs voté le texte.
Cela va nous permettre de faire
reculer la violence dans l'espace
public, les tentatives d'homicides
et la violence dans les transports
en commun.
La clé, c'est la lutte contre la
drogue.
La clé, c'est l'action sans
précédent que nous avons.
Nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler.
- Emmanuelle Anthoine: Les
chiffres sont là et les Français
ne partagent pas votre avis.
Ils attendent avec urgence une
action résolue contre
l'insécurité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin: Nous luttons
contre tous les écosystèmes,
drogue ou islamisme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Béatrice Descamps.
- Béatrice Descamps: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
Selon le baromètre de France, une
partie des Français ont été
confrontés à des pénuries de
médicaments cette année.
Celles-ci ont été multipliées par
30 en 10 ans et touchent les
antibiotiques, les anticancéreux,
les insulines, les
antiépileptiques.
Ruptures de stocks, tensions
d'approvisionnement...
Sanofi évoque une problématique
industrielle.
C'est un calvaire pour les
familles, qui se trouvent dans une
situation angoissante et dans une
profonde incertitude.
Vous avez appelé à dresser une
liste de médicaments essentiels
d'ici juin dans le but de recenser
les points de fabrication et afin
d'assurer la disponibilité à
l'échelle européenne.
Cela va se faire.
Les acteurs du secteur préconisent
une harmonisation des prix au
niveau européen, ainsi qu'une
relocalisation de la production.
Pour rappel, 40% des médicaments
de l'Union Européenne proviennent
de la Chine et de l'Inde.
60 à 80% des principes actifs y
sont également fabriqués.
Monsieur le ministre, quelles sont
vos marges de manoeuvre pour doter
notre pays d'une capacité de
production de médicaments?
De quelle façon allez-vous pouvoir
engager la responsabilité de
l'Etat, conjointement avec
l'Europe, pour assurer la
continuité de traitement face à la
pénurie de médicaments?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, il existe
effectivement des tensions
d'approvisionnement sur plusieurs
médicaments, actuellement, mais
sans risque de rupture complète.
Ces médicaments sont toujours
disponibles.
Ces tensions peuvent être liées à
des difficultés de production, de
distribution, mais également à une
augmentation des demandes, comme
lors de l'hiver dernier sur le
paracétamol et l'amoxicilline.
Des mesures ont été prises envers
les industriels, des mesures
imposant des stocks tampons pour
mieux nous approvisionner, et des
mesures qui imposent des
déclarations en cas de risque
potentiel de rupture.
Cela explique le nombre de
déclarations.
On demande également une meilleure
répartition sur l'ensemble du
territoire pour éviter qu'il y ait
des départements qui aient des
médicaments et d'autres pas.
Le gouvernement conduit une
politique de mesures concrètes
contre ces difficultés.
Je me suis engagé à une liste de
médicaments critiques avant la fin
de ce mois.
J'ai eu une première liste de 281
médicaments, aujourd'hui.
Elle va être encore ajustée.
Cette liste nous permettra de
mieux étudier la chaîne de
production de chaque médicament et
de mettre en place des mesures
concrètes.
Il y a également un plan hivernal.
Tous les hivers, nous augmentons
la consommation de certains
médicaments.
L'objectif est voulu par le
président de la République et il
est de retrouver notre
souveraineté industrielle.
Cela concerne bien sûr les
médicaments, comme c'est le cas
dans France relance, France 2030,
et, encore hier, à Choose France,
où les industriels du médicament
ont annoncé investir plus d'un
milliard d'euros dans l'industrie
du médicament en France.
J'étais, la semaine dernière, avec
mes collègues européens pour
harmoniser nos politiques dans le
cas de pénuries.
C'est ce que nous sommes en train
de faire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Jean-Paul
Lecoq.
- Jean-Paul Lecoq: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères, il y a quelques
heures, nous apprenions, à
l'occasion de la visite du
président Zelensky, que la France,
outre la livraison de matériel de
guerre, se prépare à former des
pilotes, tout en déclarant, dans
le communiqué commun publié par
l'Elysée, que la France fournira
"des capacités complètes et dans
tous les domaines".
A quand les avions?
N'êtes-vous pas en train de
franchir la frontière entre la
solidarité avec l'Ukraine,
légitime, et l'entrée en guerre de
la France?
Les députés de la Gauche Démocrate
et Républicaine soutiennent depuis
le début du conflit le camp de la
paix pour favoriser toutes les
initiatives, notamment
parlementaires, qui accompagnent
le camp de la
paix.
La voix des pacifistes ukrainiens
et russes, et du monde entier,
doit raisonner.
Elle est parfois emprisonnée.
Les opposants démocrates à Poutine
doivent être accompagnés.
Pour parvenir à la paix, quel que
soit le moment, des concessions et
des garanties de sécurité, de part
et d'autre, devront être faites.
Parvenir à des concessions semble
aujourd'hui loin de se
concrétiser, car le prix de la
paix, qui est celui de l'orgueil
des belligérants, semble moins
lourd à payer que celui de la
guerre, qui tue chaque jour des
êtres humains.
La seule offensive diplomatique
qui existe est portée par la
Chine.
On ne peut pas la laisser seule.
Compte tenu du blocage du Conseil
de sécurité des Nations Unies, que
chacun mesure, que chacun
comprend, la réunion du G7 à
Hiroshima ce week-end ne
serait-elle pas l'occasion de
travailler à un plan de paix porté
collectivement, afin d'engager au
plus vite une offensive
diplomatique pour faire taire les
armes, sauver les vies et sortir
du conflit?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député, le président
de la République a reçu dimanche
le président Zelensky, comme vous
le rappelez, et la France, avec
ses partenaires, est pleinement
engagée pour fournir à l'Ukraine
tous les moyens qui lui sont
nécessaires pour assurer sa
légitime défense.
Nous allons accroître nos
livraisons de véhicules blindés et
de défense antiaérienne.
Nous allons poursuivre
l'entraînement de soldats et
engager celle de pilotes de
chasse.
Nous allons intensifier notre aide
civile et nous allons renforcer
les sanctions contre la Russie.
Vous mentionnez aussi les
conséquences diplomatiques et
l'intense séquence qui s'est
ouverte ce week-end.
La France y joue son rôle.
Le respect de l'intégrité
territoriale, le respect de la
souveraineté des Etats sont des
principes communs qui doivent
fonder la paix juste et durable
que nous appelons tous de nos
voeux.
Ces principes seuls peuvent
permettre de l'atteindre.
Nous le rappelons à nos
partenaires.
Enfin, alors que Kiev vient d'être
victime, cette nuit, d'une
nouvelle salve de bombardements
massifs, et que la Russie continue
de cibler les infrastructures
civiles, les populations civiles,
je tiens à dire aux Ukrainiens que
nous sommes à leurs côtés et que
tous les auteurs de ces crimes
devront être punis.
Pour notre propre sécurité et pour
préserver les règles qui
façonneront le monde de demain,
l'agression russe ne peut pas être
récompensée.
Elle doit être défaite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Julie
Delpech.
- Julie Delpech: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre des Comptes publics.
Vous avez dévoilé, la semaine
dernière, votre plan de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale, qui sera
suivi, fin mai, de celui contre la
fraude sociale.
Votre parti pris semble clairement
affiché: concentrer les efforts
sur les plus grosses fraudes, tout
en allégeant en même temps la
pression sur les classes moyennes.
Votre méthode est claire: plus de
moyens, plus de sanctions pour
plus de résultats.
Je salue l'ouverture de ce
chantier, qui contribuera à
redonner confiance aux citoyens, à
ceux qui travaillent, qui
participent à l'effort commun par
l'impôt et qui ressentent parfois
une forme de sentiment
d'injustice, surtout quand la vie
est chère, comme ces derniers
mois.
Il y a des attentes fortes et vous
démontrez, à travers ces issues,
ces annonces issues de
contributions écrites de la
quasi-totalité des groupes
parlementaires qu'à l'idéologie
obsessionnelle de surtaxer tout le
monde, tout le temps, vous
préférez le pragmatisme de lutter
contre la fraude, l'évasion, de
s'assurer que chacun paye ce qu'il
doit.
Vous avez basé votre méthode sur
la relation de confiance et le
renforcement du droit à l'erreur,
deux grands progrès issus de la
volonté présidentielle.
Si l'on comprend bien les mesures
dévoilées pour lutter contre la
fraude fiscale, que pensez-vous
faire contre l'optimisation
fiscale qui apparaît, aux yeux des
Français, comme une fraude et qui,
pourtant, n'en est pas toujours
une?
Certains particuliers très
fortunés ou certaines grandes
entreprises profitent de certains
outils, comme le prix des
transferts abusifs afin d'échapper
à notre fiscalité.
Monsieur le ministre,
pourriez-vous nous détailler les
mesures que vous comptez mettre en
oeuvre afin de consolider la
justice fiscale pour tous et par
tous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Gabriel
Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
madame la députée Julie Delpech,
nous avons pour ambition de lutter
contre la fraude et contre toutes
les fraudes.
Certains veulent faire croire
qu'il n'y aurait que de la fraude
fiscale.
D'autres veulent faire croire
qu'il n'y aurait que de la fraude
sociale.
Nous assumons de lutter contre
toutes les fraudes, sans
instrumentalisation, avec la seule
volonté de rendre aux Français,
notamment de la classe moyenne et
qui respectent les règles, ce qui
leur est dû, notamment des
financements pour notre modèle
social.
C'est le sens de la feuille de
route que j'ai présentée la
semaine dernière.
Je veux rappeler les progrès qui
ont été permis ces dernières
années, notamment par la loi de
2018, qui avait été portée par
Gérald Darmanin.
C'est cette majorité qui a fait
sauter le verrou de Bercy et qui a
permis un certain nombre
d'initiatives qui nous ont permis
d'avoir une année record en
matière de fraude fiscale
identifiée.
Il faut franchir une étape
supplémentaire, aller plus loin.
Ma philosophie, c'est plus de
moyens, plus de sanctions et plus
de résultats.
Plus de moyens, ce sont des agents
supplémentaires pour le contrôle
fiscal.
1500 agents en plus dans les cinq
années à venir.
Le doublement des agents du
service des enquêtes financières,
aussi.
Quand on est dans de la bande
organisée, dans de la
dissimulation d'avoirs, on sort de
la citoyenneté.
La sanction d'indignité fiscale et
civique est, je pense, justifiée.
Vous évoquez les zones grises.
Vous avez parlé d'optimisation
fiscale, qui se fait sur des
schémas légaux qui se révèlent
abusifs.
Quand c'est flou, il y a un coût
pour les finances publiques.
J'ai annoncé un certain nombre de
mesures.
Nous avons prononcé une amende
record de 1,3 milliard d'euros,
l'été dernier...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Julie
Lechanteux.
- Julie Lechanteux: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin, ou plutôt le
ministre de la submersion
migratoire organisée.
Le président vient de déclarer
qu'il était prêt à faire tous les
référendums possibles.
Personne n'y croit!
Il a expliqué qu'il n'en ferait
pas sur l'immigration.
Les Français devront attendre
l'arrivée de Marine Le Pen pour
pouvoir se prononcer sur cette
question fondamentale pour notre
pays, pour son modèle social, pour
son identité.
Cette déclaration vient confirmer
le mépris du président pour
l'expression populaire et illustre
votre bilan désastreux, qu'il
s'agisse d'immigration illégale ou
légale.
Votre vision dans le domaine est
diamétralement opposée à celle des
Français.
Sur les 189 migrants débarqués de
l'Ocean Viking dans le Var, 123 se
sont vu refuser l'entrée sur notre
territoire, dont 3 fichés S.
Ils se sont tous échappés sans
exception.
Où sont-ils, aujourd'hui?
Qui s'en soucie?
Ce sont des conséquences
dramatiques pour la sécurité des
Français!
Quant à l'immigration légale, et
je ne parle pas des réfugiés
ukrainiens, en même temps que vous
offrez le gîte, le couvert et tous
les soins gratuits à plus de
320.000 immigrés en 2022, soit
l'équivalent de la ville de Nice,
vous abandonnez 300.000 SDF et 11
millions de Français en situation
de pauvreté, qui ne parviennent
pas à se nourrir et à se loger.
Vous persistez, avec des millions
d'immigrés légaux prévus sur notre
territoire à l'horizon 2027.
Alors que nos prisons débordent
d'étrangers, vous n'avez expulsé
que 3615 immigrés illégaux.
Alors que la plupart des mineurs
non-accompagnés ne sont pas
mineurs, vous refusez de les
tester et de les renvoyer chez
eux.
Monsieur le ministre, allez-vous
respecter la volonté du peuple?
Allez-vous protéger nos frontières
et les Français victimes de cette
immigration anarchique et massive?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, devant cette
question pleine de pondération et
de modération, dans le respect des
personnes humaines...
Oui, je sais que c'est un propos
qui ne semble pas vous toucher, le
respect des personnes humaines.
Ce que vous dites est un mélange
de complotisme, de démagogie et de
mensonge.
De complotisme, parce que vous
faites semblant de croire...
Vu qu'on m'insulte, je vais me
rasseoir.
Je répondrai à la prochaine
question.
On peut avoir un débat poli et
posé, pas énervé?
C'est possible?
Complotisme, parce que vous faites
semblant de croire que l'Etat
organise ce que vous appelez
vous-même "la submersion
migratoire".
Est-ce bien raisonnable?
Savez-vous que tous les pays
européens sont concernés par la
même situation: la détresse d'une
grande partie de personnes qui
quittent l'Asie et l'Afrique pour
venir en Occident.
Nous ne pouvons pas accueillir
tout le monde, mais faut-il y voir
un complot de l'Etat?
Du mensonge, aussi.
Vous évoquez 3 fichés S dans
l'Ocean Viking.
Je ne savais pas que vous étiez
patronne de la DGSI.
Par nature, madame...
Par nature, madame, les personnes
dangereuses se voient refuser
l'accès au territoire national.
Si vous le souhaitez, ce serait la
volonté que les policiers qui,
tous les jours, dans des
conditions confidentielles de
travail, vous puissiez avoir accès
à leur travail, mais vous
n'écoutez pas ma réponse.
En m'insultant, le but, comme à
chaque fois, ce n'est pas la
réponse, mais c'est de poursuivre
votre démagogie au service des
peurs.
La seule chose qui puisse vous
faire élire, c'est la peur que
vous entretenez tous les jours.
Je regrette que vous n'ayez pas eu
le temps de m'écouter.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Julie
Laernoes.
- Julie Laernoes: Madame la
présidente, ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur.
Monsieur le ministre, la
solidarité et nos valeurs
républicaines ont-elles
définitivement perdu face à la
haine?
Depuis l'hiver 2022, les élus, qui
respectent nos obligations
républicaines en installant des
centres d'accueil ou d'hébergement
dans nos communes, sont victimes
des attaques de l'extrême droite.
Ne nous trompons pas.
A l'origine de ces délits, de ces
crimes, c'est l'appel à la haine
de l'autre, c'est l'idéologie
proférée par des groupuscules
d'extrême droite et relayée par
des partis politiques dont
certains sont assis ici, sur ces
bancs.
Une commune a subi ces attaques
odieuses.
C'est maintenant le maire de
Saint-Brevin qui est menacé,
attaqué, et qui jette l'éponge.
C'est ainsi qu'est apparue la
maison de monsieur le maire:
noircie!
Une situation effrayante et
scandaleuse que Yannick Morez et
sa famille ont vécu.
Je
souhaite que nous lui réitérions
notre profond suspect et notre
plein soutien.
Ces faits peuvent être qualifiés
d'attentat.
C'est un acte terroriste!
Voilà le vrai visage du terrorisme
d'extrême droite qui reste bien
vivant sur notre territoire et sur
lequel nous vous avons interpellé
à plusieurs reprises.
Qu'avez-vous fait?
Qu'aurait-il pu se passer si
Yannick Morez n'avait pas
démissionné?
Monsieur le ministre, malgré
plusieurs alertes, votre ministère
n'a pas agi, n'a pas protégé ceux
qui devaient l'être.
Ce sont les fondamentaux de notre
République qui sont attaqués!
Comment, dans le pays des droits
de l'homme, est-il possible de
rester sans agir face à la bête
noire qui prospère?
Vous vous rendez complice de ces
agissements...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je crois que la Première ministre,
Christophe Béchu et moi-même avons
répondu au drame qui touche le
maire de Saint-Brevin.
Je veux dire ici qu'il touche
beaucoup d'élus de la République,
quel que soit leur mandat et leurs
opinions politiques, et quels que
soient les faits qui les poussent
à cette démission.
Vous savez, j'ai aussi été maire,
moi aussi.
Je peux constater que, lorsque
j'étais en responsabilité
municipale, comme lorsque je suis
en responsabilité ministérielle,
j'ai toujours vu les gendarmes,
les policiers et les préfets être
aux côtés de ces maires.
Je peux être totalement d'accord
avec vous sur la condamnation de
cet acte.
Je n'ai pas pour habitude de
commenter ce que fait la police
judiciaire.
Il est tout à fait vrai que, dans
vos propos, vous semblez dire que
jamais les gendarmes n'ont été
voir le maire de Saint-Brevin.
C'est tout à fait faux.
Vous avez l'impression de dire que
jamais les gendarmes ne l'ont
protégé, ainsi que le futur centre
d'accueil pour les personnes
migrantes.
Et c'est tout à fait faux.
Que le sous-préfet de
Saint-Nazaire, comme le préfet de
Loire-Atlantique, n'ont pas
contacté le maire de Saint-Brevin,
c'est tout à fait faux.
Qu'aucun membre du gouvernement ne
l'ait soutenu, c'est tout à fait
faux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Hugues Ratenon.
- Jean-Hugues Ratenon: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, trois
jours à La Réunion, accompagné de
trois ministres, d'un paquet de
conseillers, mais surtout de 400
militaires, de forces de l'ordre,
de drones, d'hélicoptères, pour
quadriller le terrain...
Du jamais vu pour ce genre de
visite.
Les journalistes réunionnais ont
été méprisés.
Vous êtes arrivé en fanfare, vous
êtes reparti comme un enfant pris
la main dans le pot de confiture.
Mépris des élus...
Vous vous êtes rendu à
Saint-Joseph sans être invité, ni
même prévenir le maire et la
députée de la circonscription.
Vous perpétuez la relation du
dominant-dominé.
Quant à nos préoccupations: 10
millions pour l'agriculture,
totalement insuffisant.
Rien sur l'autosuffisance
alimentaire.
60 millions pour deux lycées: du
réchauffé, déjà servi en décembre
2022 par votre ministre.
Rien sur l'inclusion d'élèves
handicapés, 30 millions sur la
mobilisation des ressources en
eau, soit moins de 7% du budget
global, mais rien sur la
distribution, sur la qualité, sur
l'allégement des factures d'eau.
Rien sur la cherté de la vie.
Rien sur le pouvoir d'achat.
Rien sur le maintien à domicile
des personnes âgées.
Rien sur la révision du quotient
géographique.
Rien sur l'emploi des jeunes.
Rien sur nos petites entreprises
qui souffrent.
Rien sur les conséquences de votre
réforme des retraites en
outre-mer.
Vous ne pouvez pas fuir vos
responsabilités comme cela.
Rendez-vous le 8 juin.
Nous allons stopper, dans cet
hémicycle, votre réforme qui ne
sert à rien.
En revanche, êtes-vous enfin prête
à prendre en compte nos
propositions pour le développement
des outre-mer?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Les propos que vous tenez envers
la Première ministre, envers la
délégation de ministres qui est
venue à La Réunion, aurait
peut-être eu plus de sens si vous
vous étiez rendu à son invitation.
Je crois que vous n'avez pas
rencontré une seule fois les
membres de sa délégation lors des
nombreuses réunions qu'elle a eues
avec les acteurs et les élus.
C'est vrai, monsieur le député,
vous auriez alors entendu les 60
millions d'euros annoncés par la
Première ministre pour les deux
lycées qui vont se créer à La
Réunion.
L'un pour les métiers de la mer,
l'autre pour le tourisme vert.
Vous auriez entendu les 50% de
subventions avancées par la
Première ministre pour l'habitat
dégradé qui touche l'île de La
Réunion.
Vous auriez entendu la
prolongation du travail fait pour
le logement social, qui manque
cruellement.
Vous auriez entendu les 30
millions d'euros pour
l'hydraulique.
Vous préférez faire de la
politique politicienne, ce qui
nous étonne peu.
Vous avez traité de "traître",
puisque l'on parlait de violences
tout à l'heure, les sénateurs qui
se sont rendus à l'invitation de
la Première ministre de la
République.
Retirez-vous ces propos, vous qui
avez été soutenu par le
responsable départemental du Front
National dans votre élection
législative?
Vous qui n'avez pas appelé à voter
pour le président...
Pas de leçon de morale des LFI
quand un député est élu avec les
voix du Rassemblement National et
qu'il ne s'en excuse même pas.
Vous, monsieur le député...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît, un peu de silence...
- Gérald Darmanin: Il suffit de
regarder un article du Monde, qui
n'est pas souvent favorable à
l'action du gouvernement...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Hugues Ratenon.
Vous n'avez que 2 secondes.
- Jean-Hugues Ratenon: Monsieur
Darmanin, c'est à vous de retirer
vos propos.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur...
Je suis désolée, j'ai failli vous
sauter, mon cher collègue.
C'est à vous, monsieur Paul
Christophe.
- Paul Christophe: Je vous
remercie, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
du Travail.
Monsieur le ministre, avec pour
ambition d'atteindre le plein
emploi d'ici la fin du quinquennat
et de favoriser la sortie de la
pauvreté, l'autonomie et
l'émancipation par le travail, la
refonte de l'accompagnement des
allocataires du RSA est au coeur
du projet France Travail.
A cette fin et pour garantir la
prise en charge de toutes les
personnes ayant besoin d'un
accompagnement, avec pour objectif
de ne laisser personne au bord de
la route, tous les allocataires du
RSA seront inscrits à France
Travail.
Ainsi, la question de
l'accompagnement est primordiale
dans ce dispositif, notamment en
direction de l'insertion des
allocataires les plus éloignés de
l'emploi, à partir d'un
accompagnement plus personnalisé,
plus intensif et visant à agir sur
l'ensemble des difficultés
rencontrées à partir d'une
orientation et d'un diagnostic
améliorés.
Je peux attester de l'efficacité
de l'accompagnement renforcé,
puisque nous l'expérimentons dans
le département du Nord, où nous
observons, entre avril 2022 et
avril 2023, une baisse du nombre
d'allocataires et un retour à
l'emploi supérieur à la moyenne
nationale.
Au-delà de l'accompagnement
renforcé se pose la question des
freins périphériques à l'emploi,
que ce soit en matière de
mobilité, de logement ou de moyens
de garde.
Comment envisagez-vous d'adresser
cette question des freins
périphériques?
Comment appréhendez-vous cette
notion de conditionnalité de
l'aide vis-à-vis du risque de
fragilisation des publics
fragiles?
Enfin, une matière de temporalité:
comment entendez-vous articuler ce
projet de loi avec les
expérimentations en cours dans 18
territoires pilotes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, en matière de
RSA, les résultats collectifs que
nous avons ne sont pas
satisfaisants.
Si le RSA est une des solutions de
survie pour beaucoup, ce n'est pas
à la hauteur de ce qu'on pourrait
espérer.
Sept ans après une première
inscription au RSA, 4 allocataires
sur 10 sont toujours bénéficiaires
du RSA.
Nous devons faire mieux.
Nous poursuivons cet objectif avec
la Première ministre, en
améliorant l'accompagnement.
D'abord, nous faisons en sorte que
du temps soit consacré pour lever
les freins périphériques, que vous
avez évoqués.
La question de la garde d'enfants,
d'accès au logement, la question
de mobilité, les questions,
parfois, de santé, lorsqu'il
permet à un allocataires de savoir
exactement le type de fonction
qu'il pourrait exercer...
Nous le ferons avec les
collectivités locales.
Aller plus loin et avoir un
meilleur accompagnement, c'est
aussi mettre en place des
activités d'insertion.
Nous ne sommes pas dans une
logique de travail gratuit, mais
bien d'accompagnement et
d'insertion.
Nous considérons que, pour être
efficace, il faut consacrer entre
15 et 20 heures par semaine à
accompagner le public et à lui
permettre de retrouver le chemin
de l'emploi.
Il s'agit d'être dans une logique
d'engagement réciproque.
C'est la loi de 1988, créant le
RMI, qui avait prévu cette
logique.
Si un allocataire a un parcours
adapté à ses besoins et ses
difficultés, mais refuse
délibérément d'y participer, les
sanctions pourront être mises en
place, jusqu'à la radiation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Naillet.
- Philippe Naillet: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Vous êtes venue à La Réunion il y
a quelques jours, par avion
évidemment.
Aujourd'hui, chez nous, il n'y a
pas seulement les températures qui
sont au-dessus de la moyenne, il y
a surtout le prix des billets
d'avion qui ne cesse d'augmenter.
En une année seulement, pour la
destination Outre-mer-Hexagone, le
prix moyen a augmenté de 36%.
Chacun comprend que c'est une
moyenne.
Auditionnés il y a quelques jours
dans le cadre de la commission
d'enquête pour les collectivités
régies par les articles 73 et 74
de notre Constitution, les
opérateurs qui interviennent dans
nos territoires nous ont dit que
les prix des billets d'avion ne
risquaient pas de diminuer, qu'au
contraire, ils vont continuer
d'augmenter pour des raisons
objectives.
Malgré les avancées
technologiques, c'est une
préoccupation pour les populations
de chez nous.
C'est une préoccupation, parce que
derrière, tout cela pèse
lourdement sur les Réunionnais.
Ca compromet la contribution de
chacun à son développement, le
développement du territoire.
Ca limite la mobilité pour des
raisons professionnelles de
formation, d'hospitalisation dans
l'Hexagone.
Cette situation risque d'éloigner
La Réunion de l'Hexagone et des
autres territoires.
Ca a un impact pour notre
économie.
Pour nous, prendre l'avion n'est
pas un luxe.
Nous demandons simplement que
chaque ultramarin puisse se rendre
dans des conditions raisonnables
ici, dans l'Hexagone.
Dans un rapport récent du Sénat
sur la continuité territoriale est
pointée l'absence de prise en
compte des spécificités de chaque
territoire ultramarin et du manque
d'ambition et de moyens.
Quelles mesures concrètes
comptez-vous prendre et comment
envisagez-vous l'accessibilité
financière?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: la parole est
à Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Merci.
Comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire en réponse la semaine
dernière, la question du prix des
billets est très sensible et
importante.
Je vais récapituler les actions et
vous dire que nous allons faire
plus.
La Première ministre, en visite à
La Réunion, s'est engagée pour le
développement du territoire et la
continuité territoriale.
C'est une difficulté qui concerne
beaucoup les territoires
d'outre-mer.
D'abord, dans le budget qui a été
voté cette année, c'est en cours
de déploiement, les aides à la
continuité territoriale ont été
revalorisées de 40 à 50% et en ce
moment, un programme est développé
pour l'accessibilité des prix de
l'avion.
Il y a la question de la hausse
des prix du carburant qui frappe
les outre-mer mais aussi beaucoup
de destinations longue distance
aujourd'hui.
Il faut néanmoins regarder s'il
n'y a pas de mauvais comportements
et plusieurs solutions sont à
l'étude.
D'abord, il faut maintenir une
concurrence en préservant les
compagnies aériennes et en
regardant si les restructurations
doivent être encouragées.
C'est ce que nous faisons.
Je réunirai les compagnies
aériennes dans les prochains
jours, avant la fin du mois de
mai, pour faire un point sur la
question des prix et vérifier
qu'il n'y a pas de mauvais
comportements tarifaires.
Je suis à la disposition des
ministres des Outre-mer pour faire
une réunion avec le ministère de
l'Economie, et examiner cette
question précise.
Il faut refondre les aides.
C'est un chantier que nous avons
ouvert avec Jean-François Carenco.
Si nous travaillons sur ces aides,
avec les compagnies aériennes, si
nous vérifions qu'il n'y a pas de
comportements excessifs, nous
apporterons des solutions
concrètes.
Il faut essayer de réduire les
coûts des carburants, mais nous
agirons dans les semaines à venir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jordan Guitton
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Jordan Guitton: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances.
Pendant des mois, les Français ont
payé le carburant près de 2 euros
le litre et leur pouvoir d'achat a
été contracté.
Depuis des semaines, et malgré une
légère baisse, la France est l'un
des pays en Europe où le carburant
est encore le plus cher.
La voiture n'est pas un choix,
mais une nécessité, qui s'impose
aux familles comme aux
travailleurs.
Cela est encore plus vrai dans les
territoires ruraux.
Le prix du carburant hors taxes
est l'un des plus élevés d'Europe
à cause de fortes marges sur le
raffinage et la distribution, mais
il est aussi l'un des plus taxés
d'Europe, à environ 60% du prix à
la pompe.
Il faut arrêter cette double peine
et rendre l'argent aux Français.
En adoptant des mesures qui
permettent de contrer les envolées
actuelles ou futures des prix du
carburant comme la baisse de la
TVA et la suppression des hausses
des prix, ces mesures
permettraient une baisse durable
du prix du carburant et il serait
aujourd'hui à moins de 1,5 euro le
litre.
Cette situation dure depuis des
semaines.
Pourquoi avoir annoncé seulement
il y a quelques jours que vous
alliez demander aux distributeurs
de baisser leurs prix?
Quand allez-vous appliquer enfin
la mesure pérenne portée par
Marine Le Pen et le Rassemblement
National qui concerne la baisse de
la TVA sur l'ensemble des énergies
dont le carburant et qui
permettrait de réduire les prix de
l'ensemble des énergies?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Il arrive au Rassemblement
National de réaliser que la France
n'a pas de pétrole?
Vous ne proposez aucune
proposition pour sortir de cette
dépendance.
Face aux peurs que vous agitez,
aux mensonges que vous déployez,
et Olivia Grégoire vous a déjà
répondu sur une partie de ces
mensonges, la baisse de la TVA, la
réalité des prix...
Face à votre inaction quand il
faut voter des mesures de
protection du pouvoir d'achat,
nous agissons.
J'ai exigé ces jours derniers des
distributeurs et des fournisseurs
qu'ils répercutent plus vite la
baisse des prix.
La hausse des prix des carburants
était liée aux blocages et aux
difficultés auxquelles nous avons
dû faire face, auxquelles les
Français ont dû faire face.
Cette baisse s'est concrétisée ces
derniers jours.
Nous continuons à être vigilants
sur le prix du carburant.
Cela ne nous satisfait pas.
Le gouvernement a donc pris ses
responsabilités et a mis en place
une indemnité carburant qui
bénéficie aux Français qui,
effectivement, ont besoin de leur
voiture pour travailler.
5 millions de Français bénéficient
de cette indemnité carburant, et
cette indemnité, vous ne l'avez
pas votée.
Sur la transition énergétique, qui
est la solution de moyen terme
pour permettre aux Français de ne
pas subir cette dépendance aux
énergies fossiles, vous ne faites
aucune proposition, et ces mesures
de prime à la conversion, de bonus
écologique, de leasing que nous
allons mettre en place, ces
mesures, nous les déployons
aujourd'hui.
Là encore, vous n'avez aucune
proposition précise pour
accompagner les Français.
On savait que le RN n'avait pas de
pétrole, on découvre qu'ils n'ont
pas non plus d'idées.
- Jordan Guitton: Les revenus de
la TVA ont augmenté de 46
milliards d'euros pour votre
gouvernement ces 3 dernières
années.
Arrêtez de taxer les
automobilistes!
Vous n'êtes pas les Mozart de la
finance, vous êtes les Mozart de
la taxe.
Rendez l'argent aux Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Corinne
Vignon pour Renaissance.
- Corinne Vignon: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
des Armées.
"A new frontier", expression
utilisée par le président Kennedy
dans son discours, faisait
référence aux futurs défis dans la
course à l'espace.
Compte tenu du contexte
international avec le retour de la
guerre de haute intensité aux
portes de l'Europe, cette
expression est tragiquement
d'actualité.
L'espace est devenu le nouveau
front de conflictualité.
Le 13 juillet dernier, le
président de la République a
annoncé une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire de 2024 à
2030 qui fixe les grands axes de
notre politique de défense.
Pour renforcer et étendre nos
capacités spatiales de défense, 6
milliards d'euros seront
consacrés.
Afin de répondre à cette ambition,
le commandement de l'espace aura
une infrastructure militaire et
près de 500 experts en 2025.
Ce bâtiment représentera le
symbole du spatial militaire
français.
Même si nous avons une avancée
considérable, d'autres Etats se
sont lancés dans la maîtrise de
l'espace.
Face à nous, nous avons des
compétiteurs sérieux.
Nous devons surveiller l'activité
de nos orbites, protéger nos
satellites, protéger nos
équipements militaires.
Cette nouvelle frontière est
aujourd'hui en proie à des
menaces.
Il faut une politique spatiale
ambitieuse pour la France.
Quelle est votre vision pour le
spatial afin de contrer
d'éventuelles attaques?
Comment anticiper l'évolution de
nos capacités de
télécommunications spatiales à
horizon 2030?
Après cette date, ne faut-il pas
s'appuyer sur les constellations?
Notre avancée industrielle sur
l'observation de l'espace est
indéniable, mais comment
prévoyez-vous de consolider cette
avancée?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Sébastien Lecornu,
ministre des Armées.
- Sébastien Lecornu: Vous l'avez
dit, l'ensemble de l'ambition
spatiale est de 6 milliards
d'euros.
On retrouve dedans l'enjeu sur les
télécommunications, avec l'envoi
dans l'espace d'un satellite
Syracuse.
Il y a des pistes de travail sur
des constellations en orbite basse
et des achats de services en
redondance.
On garde dans notre coeur la
souveraineté sur les gros
satellites en orbite haute et
notre propre savoir-faire et notre
propre maîtrise.
L'observation: un satellite est
prévu en 2024 dans la haute
programmation militaire et je
confirme que les discussions avec
l'industriel se sont bien passées.
La semaine prochaine, je vais
porter un amendement pour inscrire
un satellite supplémentaire Iris
dans cette période sans attendre
2032-2035.
C'est une bonne nouvelle pour
notre souveraineté et notre
service de renseignements.
On pourrait citer, mais le temps
manque, les actions en matière de
renseignements.
L'action dans l'espace est une
fonction nouvelle.
Il y a aussi des enjeux de
structuration de la filière de
commandement.
Il y aura un renfort important
dans votre circonscription.
Tout ça va nécessiter du soutien
important.
C'est l'un des pivots essentiels
de la programmation militaire à
venir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Sophia Chikirou
pour La France Insoumise.
- Sophia Chirikou: Merci.
Avec Emmanuel Macron et son
gouvernement, les Français
découvrent un nouveau best-seller,
"50 nuances de mensonges".
Après les mensonges sur les
retraites, voici les intox sur
l'industrialisation du pays.
Votre politique de casse du droit
du travail et de cadeaux fiscaux
aux investisseurs étrangers crée
des emplois selon vous, mais entre
fin 2019 et fin 2022, 3900 emplois
à temps plein ont disparu dans
l'industrie.
Il est faux de dire que les
investissements étrangers sont le
meilleur moyen de réindustrialiser
la France.
Ces investissements mettent en
danger notre souveraineté dans des
secteurs stratégiques.
En réalité, 10% des
investissements entrants sont de
l'optimisation fiscale.
Ce sont des milliards d'euros qui
échappent à l'impôt.
20% sont de la pure spéculation
immobilière qui est la cause de la
crise du logement en France.
Faites comme au Canada, interdisez
ces investissements!
Il est faux et fou d'exiger, comme
le fait Emmanuel Macron, une pause
réglementaire écologique.
Le problème de l'industrie en
France, ce n'est pas la
réglementation écologique.
Le problème, c'est le prix de
l'énergie qui menace 150.000
emplois dans notre pays.
Vous refusez de revenir aux tarifs
réglementés alors que cette
Assemblée l'a voté.
Il faut instaurer des
contreparties sociales et
écologiques.
Il faut renforcer les règles dans
l'écoconception, sujet absent de
votre projet de loi Industrie
verte.
Vous avez été condamnés trois fois
pour inaction climatique.
Ma question est simple: comment
comptez-vous faire moins que rien?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Roland Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame Sophia Chikirou, nous avons
reçu avec Bruno Le Maire, le 9
avril dernier, votre groupe, en
vous proposant de contribuer à ce
projet de loi.
Vous êtes la bienvenue pour
exposer les idées que vous avez
évoquées sur la fin de votre
question.
Vous êtes la bienvenue.
Contribuer à un projet de loi,
cela suppose d'être d'accord sur
les faits.
Les faits sont établis.
Entre 2017 et le premier trimestre
de 2023, la France a créé 90.000
emplois dans l'industrie.
Vous avez pris des chiffres.
Je vais répondre.
Vous avez pris les chiffres entre
2019 et 2022.
Si vous choisissez les dates qui
vous arrangent, vous allez
peut-être arriver à prouver ce que
vous voulez.
Entre les débuts de la Covid-19 et
fin 2022, l'industrie a quasiment
retrouvé le niveau qui prévalait
avant.
Sur l'ensemble du quinquennat, il
y a eu 90.000 emplois industriels
créés.
Ce sont des usines créées qui sont
en train de décarboner l'industrie
traditionnelle.
Vous parlez de pause
réglementaire, je vous parle de
décarboner l'industrie
traditionnelle.
Aujourd'hui, les 50 sites les plus
émetteurs sont en train d'adopter
des plans ambitieux qui font que
60% des émissions de l'industrie
française vont bientôt être un
mauvais souvenir.
On a besoin de l'industrie, on a
besoin de la décarboner, on a
besoin d'aider la nouvelle
industrie qui va créer les emplois
de demain, mais ne vous en
déplaise, ce projet de loi va
accélérer et va augmenter toutes
ces actions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Louise Morel pour
le groupe Démocrate.
- Louise Morel: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Agnès Pannier-Runacher, ministre
de la Transition écologique.
La France est plus que jamais
engagée pour mener la bataille
contre le dérèglement climatique
et pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone.
Notre pays a des atouts
stratégiques pour réussir,
notamment un mix électrique parmi
les plus décarbonés au monde,
grâce à notre parc nucléaire.
Toutefois, nous devons aller
encore plus loin, plus vite.
C'est ce que nous allons faire cet
après-midi dans cet hémicycle, en
votant pour le projet de loi
d'accélération des procédures
d'installations nucléaires.
C'est aux côtés de l'accélération
et de la production de l'énergie
renouvelable, de l'accélération du
lancement d'un grand programme
nucléaire, que notre pays va
réussir à bâtir sa souveraineté
énergétique.
En cela, n'opposons pas les
énergies renouvelables au
nucléaire.
Notre défi, c'est de mettre fin
aux énergies fossiles.
Le nucléaire n'est pas seulement
un atout pour la France, c'est
également un atout pour l'Europe.
Vous portez dans ces négociations
européennes l'intégration du
nucléaire comme énergie
essentielle à la transition
énergétique.
La France a eu de nombreuses
victoires.
Il y a eu la production
d'hydrogène décarboné avec de
l'énergie nucléaire, alors qu'elle
était tabou il y a encore peu de
temps.
Ce succès est dû à un important
travail diplomatique et de
conviction auprès de nos
homologues européens.
La question porte sur l'alliance
du nucléaire.
Vous en êtes à l'initiative.
La première réunion s'est tenue en
février à Stockholm, avec 11 pays.
Ce matin, 16 pays étaient
représentés dans votre ministère
pour une nouvelle réunion de cette
alliance.
C'est une démonstration de la
place de la France sur ce sujet et
la preuve que le nucléaire a une
place essentielle dans la
transition énergétique européenne.
Pourriez-vous nous présenter la
feuille de route de l'alliance du
nucléaire au service de la
transition énergétique européenne,
et plus particulièrement les
conclusions que vous tirez de la
réunion avec vos homologues ce
matin?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée Morel, je
partage avec vous le défi de notre
siècle: c'est de mettre fin aux
énergies fossiles.
Il ne faut pas opposer les
énergies renouvelables et les
énergies nucléaires.
Nous allons avoir besoin de ces
deux leviers, comme nous avons
besoin de sobriété énergétique et
d'efficacité énergétique.
J'appelle l'ensemble des députés
de tous bords confondus à voter le
projet de loi d'accélération des
procédures nucléaires que nous
allons regarder tout à l'heure
pour bâtir cette souveraineté
énergétique.
C'est une étape essentielle pour
lancer dans les meilleurs délais
le grand programme nucléaire que
nous appelons de nos voeux.
Nous voulons envoyer un signal
fort de soutien.
C'est une étape essentielle pour
marquer la volonté de la France de
réussir sa transition énergétique
grâce au nucléaire.
Cette volonté que je partage avec
vous, c'est celle que nous avons
partagée avec les 16 pays réunis
ce matin à Paris pour construire
cette alliance du nucléaire.
Cette alliance du nucléaire, elle
incorpore la Commission
européenne.
La commissaire européenne de
l'énergie était à nos côtés pour
discuter de notre feuille de
route.
Son but, c'est d'établir une
feuille de route ambitieuse qui
nous permettrait vite d'accélérer
notre transition énergétique,
l'accélérer en montrant que nous
sommes tous en train de lancer de
nouveaux projets qui pourraient
nous permettre de créer jusqu'à
450.000 emplois dans les années
qui viennent.
C'est considérable.
Ce sont des projets qui vont nous
permettre de soutenir la filière
nucléaire.
La France y prendra toute sa
place.
Ces projets visent également à ce
que le nucléaire soit
systématiquement inclus dans notre
stratégie énergétique européenne,
et c'est avec la plus grande
détermination que nous allons
porter cette vision.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Vincent Rolland
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Vincent Rolland: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, c'est
le printemps.
Nous sommes en montagne et comme
chaque année, nos agriculteurs
ressortent leurs troupeaux après
l'hiver.
Ils sont les ambassadeurs d'une
agriculture de qualité qui fait la
réputation du territoire,
l'entretien des paysages et la
gestion des sols contre l'érosion.
Aux yeux du grand public, cette
situation pourrait paraître
parfaite, mais elle ne l'est pas
du tout.
Pourquoi?
La réponse est simple.
C'est la pression insupportable
qu'exerce le loup sur nos
élevages.
Nos éleveurs sont à bout.
Quelques chiffres: ce sont
aujourd'hui plus de 1000 loups qui
sont présents sur le territoire
national, 12.000 bêtes qui sont
victimes de ces attaques sans
compter la faune, elle aussi
atteinte.
Ce sont aussi 60 millions d'euros
prélevés dans la poche du
contribuable pour protéger une
espèce pourtant en voie de forte
expansion.
Madame la Première ministre, le
loup est partout en France.
Il va même jusqu'à rentrer dans
nos villages.
Il tue des chiens et n'est même
plus effarouché par la présence
des habitants.
Faut-il attendre un drame humain
pour prendre des mesures
appropriées?
Nous vous demandons de changer de
paradigme avec une nouvelle
politique de gestion de l'espèce,
en facilitant les tirs par moins
de bureaucratie, en utilisant des
lunettes et des caméras
thermiques, y compris pour les
agriculteurs, quel que soit le
type d'élevage, et en supprimant
le reste à charge pour les
éleveurs.
Nous vous demandons un changement
profond de la position de l'Etat.
Il en va de l'avenir de l'élevage
comme de la vie de nos
agriculteurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Bérangère
Couillard.
- Bérangère Couillard: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député Rolland,
d'abord, nous mesurons bien sûr la
détresse des éleveurs français
face aux attaques du loup.
Nous sommes pleinement mobilisés,
particulièrement avec le ministre
de l'Agriculture, qui est absent
aujourd'hui, mais qui partage
évidemment le souhait de trouver
des solutions pertinentes et
adaptées pour y faire face.
Le loup est une espèce qui est
protégée par la convention de Bern
et qui est revenue par les Alpes
françaises depuis maintenant une
trentaine d'années.
Notre priorité, c'est d'assurer
nos engagements de protection du
loup, mais aussi, et bien sûr, de
permettre aux pastoralistes
d'exercer leur activité dans les
meilleures conditions.
Nous avons adopté en 2018 un plan
national d'action, notamment pour
la mise en place de mesures de
protection des troupeaux.
Il y a des aides au gardiennage
pour les bergers, il y a des aides
pour les achats de clôtures.
Le gouvernement met en oeuvre une
politique de tirs dérogatoires.
En 2022, 169 loups ont été
prélevés sur un plafond de 174.
Cela représente 19% de la
population.
Ce sont prioritairement les
attaques de troupeaux que nous
devons réguler.
Afin d'adopter des mesures
toujours plus efficaces et dans un
esprit de dialogue que nous
souhaitons préserver, et d'une
concertation que nous devons
assurer, j'ai lancé, à la demande
de la Première ministre Elisabeth
Borne, un plan d'action national
sur la période 2024-2029, basé sur
une concertation avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes.
On aura l'occasion d'en rediscuter
avec les parlementaires, les
organisations professionnelles
agricoles, les associations de
protection de l'environnement.
Je souhaite que ce travail
aboutisse.
Nous y sommes attachés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Vincent Rolland: Je ne suis pas
sûr que ces propos rassurent le
monde agricole.
Nous voudrions vous entendre dire
que pour le gouvernement, c'est
l'agriculture avant le loup.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Mireille Clapot
pour Renaissance.
- Mireille Clapot: Madame la
ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères, vendredi
dernier, nous avons appris la
libération de deux Français
détenus en Iran depuis plusieurs
mois, Benjamin Brière et Bernard
Phelan.
Leur grève de la faim pour
dénoncer leur détention arbitraire
a impacté leur santé.
Souhaitons-leur de se remettre de
ces terribles épreuves.
Merci aux agents du centre de
crise, merci aux diplomates
français.
Merci à vous, madame la ministre,
pour ce dénouement.
La libération et la protection des
détenus français doit être une
priorité, comme l'avait rappelé
notre Assemblée dans sa résolution
de soutien au mouvement pour la
liberté du peuple iranien en
novembre.
Malheureusement, quatre autres de
nos concitoyens sont toujours
détenus en Iran, dans des
conditions intolérables.
L'Iran utilise nos concitoyens
comme des otages d'Etat, les
accusant arbitrairement
d'espionnage, mettant en scène des
aveux forcés de leur part.
Même après leur acquittement,
certains sont maintenus en
détention ou assignés à domicile,
comme Fariba Adelkhah.
La France a soutenu le mouvement
"Femme vie liberté" et a dénoncé
la répression du gouvernement
iranien.
Cette réponse de l'Iran doit
cesser.
C'est notre diplomatie qui est en
jeu, la diplomatie féministe, de
dénoncer les violations des droits
humains.
Madame la ministre, quelles sont
les actions que mène le ministère
pour la libération et la
protection de nos concitoyens
toujours retenus en Iran?
Comment empêcher l'Iran de
continuer cette insupportable
diplomatie des otages?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée Clapot, merci de
votre question qui me permet
d'évoquer deux libérations.
Ce sont deux bonnes nouvelles.
Nous avons eu la joie de pouvoir
accueillir, vendredi dernier,
Benjamin Brière et Bernard Phelan,
de retour en France après avoir
été détenus sans raison.
Ils ont pu retrouver leurs
familles, et nous sommes tous
heureux.
Tout le gouvernement se réjouit de
leur libération.
Je suis sûr que vous vous en
réjouissez également.
Madame la députée, nous n'avions
eu de cesse de plaider auprès des
autorités iraniennes pour la
libération de Bernard Phelan et de
Benjamin Brière sur des bases
humanitaires.
L'un et l'autre étant malades,
affaiblis au point qu'ils sont
encore hospitalisés tous les deux.
Je remercie ceux qui ont oeuvré à
ce résultat.
Je vous remercie d'avoir cité
certains d'entre eux, dont des
agents de mon ministère.
Je voudrais souligner la bonne
coordination entre les différentes
administrations françaises qui ont
oeuvré pour ce résultat.
Après ces libérations et celle de
Fariba Adelkhah, il nous reste
encore à obtenir la libération de
quatre de nos compatriotes.
Nous ne relâcherons en rien nos
efforts et nous exigerons leur
libération immédiate et sans
condition.
Je tiens à rappeler que,
concernant les seuls pays de
l'Union Européenne, il reste 35
personnes retenues, ressortissants
d'une douzaine d'Etats membres et
avec lesquels nous sommes
solidaires, qui sont confrontés
comme nous à une politique
inacceptable et que nous
dénonçons.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Panot pour La France
Insoumise.
- Mathilde Panot: Vous occupez
votre poste depuis un an, madame
la Première ministre, sans que
personne ne vous ait accordé un
vote de confiance.
De 49.3 en 49.3, vous assurez le
service après-vente des caprices
du président.
Vous avez fait de notre pays une
poudrière en un an.
Bravo, madame la Première
ministre.
Aujourd'hui encore, le président
de la République vit dans une
réalité parallèle.
Emmanuel Macron est le seul qui
croit encore en Emmanuel Macron.
Vous êtes les seuls dans le pays
qui pensent encore pouvoir tourner
la page.
Nous vous répondons "Jamais"!
Jamais nous n'accepterons que vous
voliez deux ans de vie aux
Français.
Vous brutalisez les Français au
propre comme au figuré.
Le pays tout entier est opposé à
votre réforme.
Les syndicats comme le Parlement.
Bravo, madame la Première
ministre.
Quel anniversaire...
La macronie se vit à présent comme
une citadelle assiégée.
Vous diabolisez l'alternative
holistique que nous sommes, et
vous banalisez l'extrême droite.
Vous dites que nous ferions de
l'antiparlementarisme.
C'est vous,
Les extrémistes, c'est vous.
Vous avez refusé toutes les
sorties que nous avions proposées,
du référendum au retour devant le
peuple.
Jamais un gouvernement n'avait
jamais eu aussi peur du peuple.
En démocratie, il est le seul
souverain.
Madame la Première ministre, quand
allez-vous comprendre que la
représentation nationale n'est pas
une chambre d'enregistrement des
lubies du président?
Madame la Première ministre,
joyeux anniversaire, surtout.
N'hésitez pas à partir, vous, la
Ve République et votre réforme des
retraites.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame Mathilde Panot, on a bien
compris que vous étiez fâchée avec
nos institutions.
Le programme que nous mettons en
oeuvre, madame la présidente
Mathilde Panot, c'est celui sur
lequel le président de la
République a été élu.
Vous ne l'admettez pas, mais ce
n'est pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais
Emmanuel Macron que les Français
ont choisi!
Je vous le confirme, nous allons
continuer à mettre en oeuvre le
programme pour lequel le président
de la République a été élu.
Vous, de votre côté, c'est grave,
ce que vous faites: vous mentez
aux Français!
Vous mentez aux Français!
Du matin au soir, vous mentez aux
Français.
Vous voulez faire croire qu'on
pourrait d'un trait de plume rayer
18 milliards d'euros de recettes
pour notre système de retraite.
Pour une fois, dites aux Français
ce que vous proposez!
Vous proposez de baisser les
pensions, d'augmenter les
cotisations et de baisser le
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs!
Dites la vérité!
Vous êtes fâchée aussi avec le
fonctionnement de cette Assemblée
nationale.
Vous avez fait de l'obstruction.
A cause de vous, madame la
présidente Mathilde Panot, malgré
80 heures de débats, vos collègues
n'ont pas pu examiner au-delà de
l'article 3 de la réforme des
retraites.
Après l'obstruction d'un texte qui
a été approuvé, qui a été validé
par le Conseil constitutionnel,
qu'est-ce que vous proposez?
Vous proposez d'abroger la
réforme!
C'est représentatif de ce que vous
êtes, madame la présidente
Mathilde Panot, et de votre
groupe: des propositions, jamais,
mais attiser la colère, empêcher
le Parlement de fonctionner, c'est
votre mode de fonctionnement.
Nous voulons proposer des réponses
aux Français.
Tout à l'heure, je vais engager
des concertations avec les
organisations syndicales et
patronales pour construire de
nouveaux progrès!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La séance est suspendue.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA